l'été dernier j'ai visité le valhalla
bon ce n'est pas exactement ce à quoi je
m'attendais et je n'ai pas croisé loki
nul mais je me suis dit que cette visite
était l'occasion de lancer un petit
format mythologie nordique
parce que j'adore ça c'était donc en
gros trip avec ma mère quand elle m'a
dit que sur la route du retour
on allait visiter le valhalla forcément
j'étais super emballé même si je savais
pas trop à quoi m'attendre et je n'ai
pas voulu poser plus de questions que ça
parce que je préfère découvrir l'endroit
est pas trop savoir où je vais mettre
les pieds je savais donc pas du tout ce
que j'allais voir mais je m'attendais à
une sorte d' anciens temples païens
peut-être et là je vois surgir au détour
d'un virage cette immense temple dorique
qui surplombait le danube planté dans
une colline on s'était pas du tout le
valhalla mais ça en jeter quand même en
fait le valhalla allemand est une
reproduction du parthénon athéniens
construit entre 1830 et 1840 de à la
demande du roi l'eau est premier de
bavière
le but était d'en faire un mémorial des
personnes qui ont illustré la
civilisation allemande
un peu comme notre panthéon locale elle
se trouve en bavière près de ratisbonne
et c'est donc un immense temple
néoclassique en marbre qui fait 66
mètres de haut avec une porte d'entrée
monumentale et des décorations qui en
jette à l'intérieur dans tous les sens
vous sentez que je suis pas historienne
de l'art de formation en tout cas
c'était très impressionnant aussi bien
de loin que de près et loué premier a
réussi son coup ça arrange est on y
trouve 129 buste ou inscription de
personnalités allemandes allant de
l'antiquité au xxème siècle en passant
par charlemagne quelques roi wisigoth
fretey les premiers barberousse nicolas
copernic charles quint catherine ii de
russie emmanuel kant albert einstein
bref la liste est très longue et je
remettrai incitant description vous
retrouverez tous les noms mais quel
rapport avec notre valhalla nordiques me
direz vous dans le bâtiment et autour
j'ai surtout retrouver une influence
grecque même si les statuts des frontons
qui évoque des victoires grecs sont
apparemment des représentations des
walkyries le valhalla allemand est un
mémorial des personnes les plus
illustres en allemagne tout comme le
valhalla nordique accueille les plus
grands héros derrière ces portes et la
comparaison s'arrête là
un peu déçu mais impressionné par le
bâtiment j'ai repensé aux vrais valhalla
nordique
celui que j'ai découvert grâce à tort et
j'assume cette référence et sur lequel
j'ai beaucoup lu depuis pour les récits
qui nous rapportent les mythes nordiques
ont surtout été écrit par des moines
catholiques
et il semble être influencé par tout un
tas d'autres mythes indo-européen donc
les difficile de savoir en quoi croyez
exactement les scandinaves mais d'après
la plupart des récits leval roll ou
malala écrivait le avec un v ou en w
comme ça vous chante et le hall dans
lequel sont accueillis les héros c'est
l'un des palets d'odin le dieu principal
des vases à la fois dieu de la guerre de
la victoire de la sagesse de la
sorcellerie de la mort il a un sacré
pedigree le valhalla se situe dans le
royaume d'asgard demain dès 9 3 yom de
l'arbre monde est décrit comme un hall
décoré de bouclier doré de côte de
maille et de lens on y trouve cinq cent
cinquante pièces dont un rôle immense
bisquer remirent appartenant à thor le
dieu de la foudre
odin sais qu'un jour surviendra le
ragnarok en gros la fin du monde et que
le seul moyen de combattre ce ragnarok
est de rassembler à ses côtés une horde
de guerriers féroces et courageux c'est
donc dans sa demeure du valhalla qu'il
fait venir les guerriers tombés au
combat
les autres morts de la mythologie
scandinave sont envoyés au el aïn le
royaume des morts pour être plus précise
il prend seulement une moitié des
guerriers morts et l'autre est envoyé au
folk vendre le palais de la déesse
freyja la parité pour amener les
guerriers au valhalla odin le renvoi
c'est walkyrie celles qui choisissent
les morts une fois arrivé dans le palais
les guerriers morts sont appelés des
iron iard ils peuvent passer leurs
journées à s'entraîner pour se préparer
aux ragnarok et à festoyer
ils mangent la viande du sanglier
s'aérer venir qui suffit à tous les
nourrir et se régénère chaque matin et
boivent l'hydromel produit par la chèvre
broute que chacun rêverait d'avoir chez
soi
bon ça fait beaucoup de nos compliqué en
une seule vidéo alors j'espère que je ne
vous ai pas trop perdus et que ce format
vous a plu c'est possible que je refasse
ça en parlant d'autres aspects de la
mythologie scandinave ou alors en
racontant certains restent même si nota
bene fait aussi très bien ça dans ces
mythes et légendes et pour ce mois de
janvier il n'y aura pas de chronique de
profs parce que j'ai vraiment pas eu
tant de fichiers énormément le livre sur
les prochains sujets que je voudrais
aborder et donc j'attends d'être plus à
l'aise avec ces sujets là pour les
écrire et les filmer il y aura donc
sûrement une autre petite vidéo parce
que j'ai pas envie de vous laisser sur
votre faim avec juste cette vidéo du
valhalla
je vais sûrement refaire un nom de
lahmada ce que savait pas mal plus
pendant l'été et
je ne dis pas encore sûr tout petit je
vais parler mais ça sera bien et en
février par contre ni de profs reviendra
j'espère que j'arriverai à tenir tous
les mois par la suite voilà je vous
souhaite de festoyer tel et iron hier du
valhalla
en espérant que j'ai pas trop écorché
leur nom parce que je ne parle pas cette
langue et à bientôt
au revoir